welcome back everyone to the beginner to
Master speedrun episode number 26 before
we get into the chest today I do want to
give a big shout out to ABIA Villas I'm
still in Bali Indonesia and ABIA Villas
was nice enough to give me few nights
free stay so I figured I'd do a behind
the scenes Villa tour to start this
episode and I have a different camera
angle here and you can see my setup you
can see the room
it's super super spacious uh it's been
super comfortable just made some tea
which I'll drink during the
chest and this is just the beginning cuz
if we go
outside I do have a private
pool and weather here is very warm it's
so nice escaping the cold winter in the
US uh so I've been taking daily
swims and uh yeah there's so much
Greenery there a little kitchen area
where been mainly making tea everyday
breakfast is delivered so whether you're
a Solo Traveler like me or you're on
your honeymoon and you want a nice place
to stay in Bali uh can highly recommend
these Villas I'll leave more information
in the video description if you want to
check them out and let's get back to the
chest first opponent playing K
SLE and I'll play
E4
we have a Kings Pawn now the previous
episode we did see a Stafford Gambit uh
a little bit curious if we see a repeat
which we don't and normally throughout
the series I've been playing a lot of
like standard Italian but I'm going to
mix up the openings today and I'll play
the first
ponziani of the speedrun uh ponziani is
one of my favorite kind of beginner
friendly openings the idea is to take
the center right away and my opponent's
playing a very rare kind of counter
Gambit chess.com is calling this a Pon
xani counter Gambit um and it's a tricky
line because if I take the pawn then
black can expand with Pawn E4 so the
best move is actually to play D4 and
it's a line I've studied in the past but
not something I've looked at so recently
and now after Pawn takes Pawn I can take
on E5 so we have a trade of
Pawns black uh playing very quickly here
takes on E5 I'm briefly considering
Queen H5 check but that would allow
Knight G6 so I should just take back the
Knight and yeah already kind of
a imbalanced position um definitely want
to be aware of this diagonal but Queen
H5 runs into G6 now so probably not the
best uh way forward with Pawn D5 I could
on
pant actually taking on pant looks nice
cuz whatever it takes back I'm going to
have Queen A4 check and I think I'll be
winning the pawn on e4 in the
end so yeah let's go ahead and
take there are cases where white likes
to leave the pawn there to restrict
Black's
development um but now the question is
do I actually want to go for Queen A4
and win the pawn
because I would be violating some
principles like bringing my queen out
and moving it a bunch of times and if
Queen A4 there's Bishop D7 Queen
takes Black's developing pretty
quickly but then I'll have Bishop F4
with Tempo so I think this makes sense
to go
for another thing I should point out is
if Queen
C6 uh yeah I I guess I can point it out
by making the move
uh Bishop B5 is now winning the queen so
opponent played a little bit too quickly
there um I am down on time but nice
being up a queen and I'll use my queen
to hopefully win some more
material take the
pawn and let's try and show no
mercy play at a faster Pace here King d8
I wonder if that was a mouse slip like
black maybe intended casting Queen side
now it's time to develop Bishop
F4 and the strategy is really to get the
Rooks into play as quickly as possible
try and make use of the
defile with Knight
D5 I think I'll play C4 first attacking
the Knight preparing Knight
C3 yeah don't mind the trade and yeah
Knight C3 Rook D1 Rook E1 all coming
very soon
I think black is probably preparing
G5 now maybe I could play Queen
F7 yeah really trying to show no mercy
Queen
F7 pretty much trapping The
Rook yeah now winning The
Rook uh there's no great discoveries for
v i mean the queen pins the bishop in
end so opponent resigns after 19 moves
um yeah I think my opponent just played
a little bit too quickly that game uh
didn't spend more than a minute for all
the moves uh they did play like a really
aggressive approach for black this F5
line is not something I encounter so
often and um yeah usually within the
ponani like whether black plays this or
this or this or even F5 uh White can
just play D4 the only move that white
doesn't play D4 against against is if
Pawn D5 and that's where white can play
Queen A4 and I've played this in a lot
of other games that you can probably
find on my channel but yeah this was a
nice demonstration of just how to deal
with this opening and after takes takes
um I don't think taking is the most
common like usually stronger players who
play this as black will play Knight F6
or queen F6 and I can share some basic
strategy for white uh if black plays the
main line here like Knight F6 is
definitely more common and the strategy
here for white is to play this nice move
Queen B3 to threaten Checkmate and this
induces black to play D5 and then white
can play Bishop B5 pinning this Knight
and if Bishop D7 white can pin the other
Knight and this is a nice way to just
keep developing and keep the pressure on
so of course the biggest mistake for my
opponent in this game was plundering the
queen uh Bishop D7 should have been
played opponent probably should have
taken a bit more time and after takes uh
it's interesting cuz locks down a pawn
but is ready to Castle and try and use
the Central files but I think I would
have been pretty comfortable here with
Bishop F4 and White's developing pretty
rapidly as well so hopefully some basic
lessons to take away from that game uh
let's move on to the next
one playing G5 and play E4 if I get the
chance I'll play another
ponzani might be a ponziani themed
episode maybe the opponent was
considering Stafford but uh yeah back to
back
ponzani there have been requests for me
to mix up my openings for this series
and I'm pretty sure there's been
specific requests for the
ponzani uh here we see kind of a random
move A6 which
doesn't do much and again general rule
in ponani if you can play D4 on move
four you should just play it and taking
over the
center and the reason why this is such
an easy opening to play at the lower
level is very often you get the two
Center pawns and white just has really
fluid development uh both Bishops can
come out with no issue uh with Bishop to
B4 the bishop is pinning my knight now
so black is threatening Knight takes E4
but there's a few ways to deal with this
uh I have Bishop D3 I have Pawn E5 I
Bishop
G5 so take a moment here to consider my
options I mean Pawn E5 I think is the
first move I'm looking at because it's
one of the most
forcing uh would allow black to put on
more
pressure with Knight D5 Knight
E4 so I think what I'll do is I'll just
develop and
defend and then maybe later like once my
king is castled I can start considering
E5 yeah black castles I'll
castle and if I get the chance I'd
really like to play Bishop G5 and then
um eventually play E5 D6 is a logical
move uh preparing perhaps Bishop to
G4
so actually going to take a moment here
I don't think I want to allow Bishop G4
the black gets to play this move then
there's some issue with my D Pawn being
undefended because my knight would be
pinned so I'm going to play very safe
move here Pawn
H3 there's cases a move like H3 isn't
Justified but in this case because
Bishop G4 was was like the most active
developing Square for the
bishop um I think it makes sense and
yeah if the bishop were to develop to E6
I would have D5 black does have to be
careful and now I'll continue with my
own development Bishop
G5 maybe threatening this or this
definitely want to be looking to exploit
the pinned Knight now black attacking my
Pawn on
D4 so
yeah I mean this and this both look very
attractive I'm going to start
calculating Pawn E5 because after takes
takes the Knight supports the
pawn it seems very close to winning
material I think black would have to
eventually Counterattack with
H6 and then am I winning anything there
like Bishop
H4 and then G5
it looks really good because there's
cases where I get the pawn to F6 and
Black's King side would would really
open up so yeah let's go for
E5 very
straightforward yeah we see the trade of
Pawns H6 is probably the best
try but I think I'm either going to be
winning material here or just getting a
monster attack against Black's
King so we'll see what black wants to go
with yeah black takes the pawn with a
knight so I win a knight for a
pawn and I'm definitely not looking to
slow down my attack on the king side uh
but with H6 yeah I'll probably have to
move the
bishop um I mean generally when you're
upm
material it can make sense just to try
and trade and simplify but in in this
case because the Knight is pinned I
think I just want to keep the pin and I
really wouldn't mind seeing G5 which
would further weaken Black's King
side and if black doesn't play G5 then
probably looking to pressure the Knight
next move like Knight E4 or queen
F3 so life is pretty good
here
Queen D6 it's actually a good move um
unpinning the Knight and
counterattacking my
knight so I guess it's a question do I
want to support my knight I could move
back to C4 hit the
bishop have a few good options here
there's also Bishop G3 to align with the
queen one thing about Bishop G3 if I
were to play this move and then let's
say like employ some discovered attack
there might be Queen takes G3 cuz my F
Pawn would be
pinned so I'll just play the simple move
Knight
C4 mainly looking to induce some
trades I mean what I might go for is
Knight takes B6 and then eventually
Bishop takes
F6 and here I can probably start with
F6 especially because the queen is no
longer supporting the Knight this will
induce double
pongs
now the simple option would be to take
the
bishop I am looking at a tricky move
here though that and honestly might be
one of the best
moves uh Knight E4 is an option to hit
the queen and hit the pawn but with
Knight E4 the threat is very direct and
would probably provoke Queen E7 and
black would maybe still be holding on so
the move I'm looking at is Knight
D5 which looks like it blunders the
Knight but the Knight is basically
defended by the tactic Bishop H7 and
then I would win the queen and meanwhile
I'm attacking the bishop again attacking
the pawn and preventing Queen E7 because
Knight controls that
square so yeah let's go with
this oh no my
knight let's see if black wants to take
it this is the benefit of having extra
material in a pretty open position
um there's just more more tactics to
generate
so we'll see if black uh falls for the
Trap it's actually very difficult here
because it's not easy to find a move to
defend the pawn maybe King
G7 Queen D4 also looks risky but
actually Queen D4 would allow takes and
then takes and then again Bishop H7 to
win the
queen
so opponent just resigns uh I was not
expecting them to resign in that
position but another pretty smooth
ponziani win and I think the main
mistake for my opponent this game was
playing A6 just a little bit too slow in
the opening giving me time to take over
the center and uh that eventually led to
some early middle game tactics so
generally if you're black and you're
facing the ponzani uh of course F5 as we
saw the previous game is an aggressive
option but the two most common options
are Knight F6 to attack the pawn E4 or
Pawn to D5 which is one of my favorite
moves the idea being if takes and then
takes the Knight can't develop to C3 to
attack the queen uh there is some Theory
here with Queen A4 and uh yeah if you
want more analysis on these lines you
can check out some of my ponziani videos
but uh yeah pretty smooth game overall
let's move on and do at least one more
wow I'm white three games in a
row are we GNA have backto backto back
panis please play
E5 opponent taking
time taking a lot of time E5 it
is okay three ponan in a row
I mean I've I've played 85 games before
this episode and didn't have a single
ponziani now we have three in a row and
again opponent um allowing Pawn D4 and
Bishop C5 is a little bit ironic because
it looks like black is trying to control
D4 but Bishop C5 actually makes D4
stronger as it's supported by the pawn
the Knight and the Queen and black will
be losing time having to move the bishop
again um a lot of beginner players will
fall into this as black and maybe I
should stopped saying beginner players
cuz yeah 1300 maybe I can say amateur
players um I've definitely passed the
level of like the the early 400s and
500s so opponent taking time usually
it's me with a Time deficit because I do
take a lot of time to try and explain
every move but I think my opponent is
realizing the the difficulty of their
position from early on also realizing if
I win this game I'll get to
1301 it's eight rating points to win
I've mentioned this in previous episodes
but I think everyone should know that
all my opponents will get their ratings
refunded um this is an authorized
speedrun account on chest.com is labeled
on my profile so yeah I assume most most
players eventually find out that they're
playing me so opponent taking a lot of
time gives me time to drink some
tea I think we're definitely seeing the
full spectrum of time management in this
episode because my first opponent today
uh basically blitzed out every single
move didn't spend more than a minute
this game were I mean my opponent's only
made three moves
and uh spent about 2 and a half
minutes so I mean from Black's
perspective they should probably take
and then after takes Play Bishop to B4
and then I can block the check with
Knight C3 and we can actually get a
similar type of position from what I had
last game with white having the two
Center pawns and very easy development
and black being a little bit behind on
space I think my opponent might be
breaking the record for the longest time
spent thinking on a single move uh in
this
series uh I can't recall any opponent
spending more than a minute to 90
seconds on on one
move and I should note this is 10-minute
chess with no increment so it's
considered rapid chess and generally
with this time control you don't want to
be taking several minutes especially
early on in the game but opponent does
play the best
move and now has to decide what to do
with the
bishop and Bishop B4 is most natural
Bishop B6 also
playable so I'll keep
developing it's a very similar position
to the previous game mean if black
throws in A6 it would be super similar
but I think I'll continue with like the
same ideas like if we see Knight F6 okay
Queen E7 makes things a little bit
different um
now I think I still want to put the
bishop on D3 generally Bishop C4 is a
more active Square to eventually Target
F7 but with Queen E7 and Knight F6 and
potentially D5 coming I think I want to
make sure that the E4 Pawn is well
reinforced so I'll play Bishop
D3 just preparing to Castle
black plays Pawn
D6 and there is a move here
that I'm kind of tempted to play is Pawn
D5 the idea would be that if the Knight
moves then Queen A4 check although I'm
realizing that that line would backfire
for me because after Bishop D7 Queen
takes B4 there's Knight takes D3 I lose
back the bishop and then I lose my queen
as as well with a fork in the
end
so castling is probably the most natural
move but I think I'm going to use the
same idea from the previous game uh with
D6 black definitely wants to develop the
bishop to G4 to pin my knight and
pressure the D4 Pawn so I'm going to
start with
H3 and I think this is a very useful
move to keep in mind in a lot of these
ponziani positions uh whenever black
wants to put the bishop here
it can make sense to spend a Tempo to
prevent it uh and now I can
castle and now with castling I'm
actually setting up a trap which my
opponent didn't fall into uh I can show
after the game that if takes takes takes
uh I would have had tactics on E
file so with casting King side I'll
complete development pinning the Knight
to the
queen I mean this setup looks very very
familiar
I in pretty much the exact same setup I
employed in the previous
game and E5 and Knight D5 are probably
the go-to
ideas me Knight D5 actually looks like a
very attractive
threat to attack the Queen the Knight
the bishop the
pawn and again if Bishop E6 I have the
fork with Pawn to
D5 so it's one of these situations where
like material is equal but because I'm
controlling more space and black is just
a bit more limited in terms of the
squares that they can access it's a very
difficult position for black to play
it's like really hard to find an active
move or just a plan to improve the
pieces a move like Bishop takes C3 would
help strengthen my center and maybe this
is the best move though to just not
allow Knight
D5 so my time Advantage is
increasing I'm actually trying to
imagine what I would do in this position
as black Bishop takes C3 would
definitely be a a candidate move I mean
maybe G5 is worth it because the pin is
just so annoying
[Music]
here like sometimes when the opponent is
taking a long time to think it can be a
useful exercise to try put yourself in
their shoes and try and imagine what
they might be coming up with so we do
see Bishop takes
C3 now yeah Knight D5 is not going to
happen for
me but probably what I'll be looking to
do is prepare this move Pawn
E5 maybe start with Rook e
one if it's my move and I play Pawn E5
right away then after takes and takes
and
takes I don't think that's worth going
into Rook E1 black could take with
check and again I'm not sure what black
should be doing here uh like maybe
bishop D7 and Rook
E8 like maybe if I were black here I'd
consider playing
G5 black going for B6
so perhaps looking to
Fen it's actually a decent looking move
I think my opponent understood the fact
they can't play Bishop E6 Bishop maybe
has more purpose on
B7
so yeah now I can take my time me
up almost five minutes on the
clock Rook e
one let's imagine Rook e one Bishop B7
and then
E5 and that looks pretty good like
Black's going to probably have to deal
with this threat
now black would like to play Queen E6 to
keep the Knight defended but that would
walk into Pawn
[Music]
D5 and now yeah Pawn E5 take take the
Knight and Rook support the
pawn let's go for
it I mean we're pretty much seeing the
same middle game idea in backto back
games like same opening same Pawn
thrust and G5 is a Counterattack uh but
the issue for black is I could take the
Knight to Counterattack the queen on
E7 I'm also tempted to take on G5 and
just blow open the black king
side I think both moves are acceptable
like Pawn takes Knight is far
simpler because if I take and then take
and then take my Knight's no longer
supporting the pawn and after takes
takes yeah I don't want to muddy the
waters let's just take on
F6 and now I'm up uh a knight for a
pawn and I'll Retreat the
bishop and the game is still alive
though it still takes some work to win
this
and yeah now I have to kind of figure
out what my plan is going
forward um the first moves that come to
mind are queen C2 or queen B3 just to
connect the
Rooks another idea is Bishop C2 to get
the queen to D3 and form the battery but
I think I'd rather start with connecting
the Rooks
first and yeah let's start with Queen
C2 just making it so if Rook takes Rook
I can
recapture now the Rooks are having a
staring
contest I'm thinking one plan going
forward might be to maneuver the Knight
especially like on F3 it's not really
doing that much and it's just a Sitting
Duck now the bishop and queen are
targeting
it
so there's a fancy move here Knight H2
to
prepare Knight
G4 that's one
idea I could also consider Bishop E4
just offering the trade of
Bishops also Knight E2 to get to
E4 so choices
choices actually not super fond of
Knight H2 because that would allow H5
preventing Knight G4 threatening to trap
my Bishop so Bishop E4 looks like the
the simplest
option just neutralizing the diagonal
offering the trade of
Bishops if takes I'll have a choice
whether to take with queen or with
Rook so I think taking with queen is
acceptable but after another
five I don't think I really want to go
into the line where I give away my queen
for two Rooks I'd rather just take back
with rook and yeah just be up uh a clean
piece now preparing the double up on the
eile okay Knight F5 so attacking the
bishop we'll go for rookie
one I don't mind if there's a trade like
the pawn would get doubled but the
position would also
simplify and now I'm going to take with
Queen very nice Central Square Rook E8
can't be played hitting the Rook keeping
pressure on the
Knight black takes and I'm curious how
many people would just automatically
recapture the knight uh because that's
not the best move I can start with
taking the Rook with
check the so-called in between move or
his wish Z and now I can take the
Knight so now I'm up a knight and a
rook and that's GG so uh nice smooth
ponzani win um yeah it's nice having
every single game in the same opening
especially one of my favorite beginner
friendly openings so I don't think
there's much to say about this game
apart from the fact that yeah black
should not play Bishop C5 against Pawn
iani like Knight F6 or D5 uh again if
you want more instruction about this
opening I'll link a video below um I do
have a few videos on my channel I think
the one I'll link below is like a 1hour
lesson that I had a few years ago with
um a pretty well-known streamer Fundy he
was playing in POG Champs and I shared
all my secrets about the
ponziani so anyway uh hope you guys
enjoyed this episode as always if you
have questions leave them below if you
like the content do subscribe does help
the channel and I'll see you guys soon